well in just a few hours here a new
coronavirus test site will open at
cashman center
it is replacing the drive-through
testing site at texas station
that one was outside this new one will
be inside which is some good news
because it is hot
and our hector mejia is live now with
more on this good morning hector
yeah it's warm outside so it's great
news we are indoors with air
conditioning good morning to you alex so
once patients arrive they'll walk inside
as we were mentioning and
a registration table based on your last
name will have your information
as well as a self-administered test kit
for covet 19. so you pick that up
you greet someone here through a
plexiglas shield and then you walk over
to one of the tables at the very back
end of the room now those are five
stations where you'll get guidance on
how to administer
this test for covid19 and we're talking
about
a mid nasal swab test for covid19 and
today for day one
clark county and university medical
center are anticipating some early lines
outside
the facility will operate five days a
week from
8 am to 4 pm tuesdays through saturdays
here at cashman center which is
owned by the city of las vegas
councilwoman olivia diaz represents ward
3.
she says this will be a convenient
location for not only the entire county
but also
for the hispanic community it's a
demographic saying
a rapid increase in covet 19 cases here
in the county
we know latinos are more likely to work
in industries with high levels of public
interaction
such as health care industries grocery
stores service industry
and that's why it's so important for
everyone not just the latino community
to take precautions
so how often should you get tested umc
is making changes and yesterday they
said
the cdc updated its recommendations to
avoid unnecessary testing right now if
you tested positive
there is no need to get a repeat test
for a negative result
umc said what patients need to do is
continue with isolation
and seek medical attention if you are
short of breath have chest pain or do
not feel okay
appointments are available through umc's
website they are encouraged to
reduce the amount of time you spend here
they're encouraged but they are not
required and one more thing to add is
the testing here
is available for children as well